I recognize that some people feel diminished by geologic time—that humans
are made insignificant by it. And I can understand that. I think it helps to
start developing some depth of field in
thinking about time. I had a math teacher
who was fond of saying, 'There are many sizes and shapes of infinity.' And while
geologic time is not infinite, it is long.
Some past events like the Pleistocene,
the Ice Age, happened just the other day. Others, say the formation of Pangaea, a
while ago. And some, the origin of life
for instance, a long time back. It's also
useful to adopt the Greek distinction
between 'chronos'—raw time billions and
billions of years—and 'kairos,' which is
time within a narrative. As one starts
knowing Earth's story, and those vast
stretches of geologic time are filled
with narratives, protagonists and plot lines, it's no longer alienating. The
characters become familiar, the themes resonant. Once we open a few volumes in
the library of deep time, we can begin to recognize ourselves in the tales of
earlier Earthlings. Indeed, I find the
idea of a seven or eight thousand year
old Earth—with a shallow, short history—
positively terrifying, while the
enveloping presence of so many ancestors, with such a rich anthology anthology of
life stories to share, is to me deeply
comforting.